in this video I'll be showing you how to
make percussion caps using
strike-anywhere matches in tin foil and
the science behind how it works for this
project you'll need a box to
strike-anywhere matches a mortal and
pestle a sheet of tinfoil scissors wire
cutters and a napkin or tissue paper it
also helps to have some kind of
precaution a cap gun but a hammer works
just as well to make sure your matches
are strike-anywhere matches as I tend to
have a larger match heads in box storage
matches use your wire cutters should cut
out the match head but make sure you
don't cut any wood off the match stick
as this will make it more difficult to
grind up the match heads try to cut off
the white tip with a little of the green
showing you can use scissors for this as
well but I find the wire cutters provide
a much more smooth and accurate cut than
scissors I've cut about eight match
heads in total but you only need about
three to four for one percussion cap now
we're going to grind up the match heads
and do a fine powder but be very careful
to break out the masses slowly and
gently press lightly with slow grinding
motion and don't hammer it like you're
tenderizing meat the more steadier and
slower the better the result if you
pound too hard you could ignite or
detonate the matches
once the matches are broken up they're
very shock sensitive so grind slower
with less pressure if you grind too fast
you'll detonate it too and this goes
without saying but this powder ignites
very easily the no open flames nearby
now you should have a nice fine powder
it doesn't have to be like flour but
make sure there's no large chunks now
we'll make the actual precaution cap cut
a piece of tinfoil long enough to cut a
square about the size of a small
matchbook you'll need three in total
then lay the three sheets over each
other now this is where it's handy to
have a precaution pistols but don't
worry if you don't have one you can use
the blunt end of an unsharpened pencil
with either a precaution pistol or
pencil eraser multiple sheets of tin
foil over the nipple of the pistols or
the blunt end of the pencil just so you
make an indentation in the foil use the
hammer of the pencil to help mold the
foil over the nipple this indentation
will then hold the powder don't press
too hard or you might tear the foil once
you have an indentation that's deep
enough cut the extra tinfoil off around
the indentation just so it looks closer
to a real percussion cap next we're
going to fold a piece of paper in half
and then pour a match powder into the
crease hold the folded paper over the
percussion cap and gently tap the powder
in it's ok if not all the powder goes
into the cap you only need a small
amount but make sure it's enough to fill
up the indentation next grab your napkin
and unfold it into a single ply cut out
a small piece about the size of the cap
this will act as a widen to hold the
powder in the cap and also to compress
the powder and when you prime it on your
pistol lay the napkin piece over the
percussion cap and press gently now
Prime the pistol make sure to fold the
percussion cap around the nipple to
secure it in place and to prevent any
powder from falling out alright let's
see how this works
not bad but let's try a second cap with
more powder and outside now if you're
curious how this works the match head is
composed of phosphorus Esquith sulphide
and potassium chlorate when the
phosphorus s the sulphide in potassium
chlorine are mixed and exposed to shock
from friction or pressure
the combination yields an exothermic
reaction yielding potassium chloride
phosphorus pentoxide
and heat if you have any questions for
science don't forget to post in the
comments below and if you want to see
more videos don't forget to subscribe
thanks for watching